[Music]
the state of 3d printing to a goes two
ways there's people who are developing
machines that can print with materials
that we currently use through to the
traditional manufacturing processes and
there's people that are developing
platforms based on on multiple materials
and this will enable a broad range of
Amiel applications by being able to
manufacture products that we were not
able to manufacture through traditional
techniques we've developed a low-cost
multi-material 3d printing platform that
can print with up to ten materials and
it's machine vision enabled so we use
machine vision techniques to enhance or
amplify the capabilities of current
multi material printing technologies we
call our project Mehta cloud and with
motiva you integrate these two worlds of
traditional manufacturing and 3d
printing and by putting them together
you you can create all new range of
objects that we haven't been able to
make today the machine vision system
integrated and multi fab allows us to
easily and very quickly calibrate the
printing system second we use machine
vision to integrate existing components
into the printing process so imagine we
put components into the printers built
platform we scan the objects and then we
use the 3d geometry information to print
the objects around those existing
objects right now a big portion of the
3d printing kind of hardware that's
available is focused on printing form
and objects for prototyping the holy
grail is to print things that are fully
functional right out of the printer
combining multiple materials with many
different properties but also existing
objects that have some inherent
functionality we printed a lens's on top
of LEDs we put this existing LED into
the printer we printed lines
designers and engineers are used to
designing with more one materials so the
whole design paradigm how we actually
design products and objects will have to
change and that's gonna require new
hardware that's gonna require new
software and that's gonna require whole
new platforms and it's gonna we're gonna
have to change the way us engineers and
designers think about design and
creating products and objects
[Music]